have you spoken to Tim Davey yet Mr
lineker standing his ground and being
kept off air days on from Gary lineker's
suspension by the BBC the ripples are
getting bigger the former footballer
made social media comments comparing the
government's rhetoric on Asylum Seekers
to language used in 1930s Germany now
Sports coverage on the Network's been
hugely disrupted as commentators and
analysts refused to work in solidarity
but here now is the best action from
today's Premier League matches the
flagship show match of the day was a
short some would say bizarre version
with no commentary or presenters
are now opposition politicians are
accusing the corporation of caving in to
political pressure I think the Tory MPS
have put intolerable pressure on the BBC
because they don't like the criticism of
their government policy and whether you
agree with what the language Gary
lineker used or not he should be able to
express his views earlier in the week
government supporting newspapers called
forlinica to go but the BBC's director
General Tim Davey says the decision was
driven by concerns of impartiality not
political pressure
one complicating Factor the issue of the
BBC's chairman Richard Sharp he's a
major conservative party donor linked to
the arranging of a loan for the former
prime minister Boris Johnson as he was
applying for the BBC job he denies any
conflict of interest what needs to
happen as a result of not just the
discussions about Gary lineker but also
about the chairman of the BBC following
the independent investigation that's now
happening is that we need to make sure
we maintain that trust in the
independence and the impartiality of the
BBC as for the substance of lineker's
criticism the government's admitted its
Asylum legislation could break
international law some government
critics here in the UK say this whole
rail is being used to distract from real
discussion of Asylum policy but others
say it's thrown up important questions
about the people who run the BBC and
their relations with the politicians
Richard Sharp and Tim Davey appear too
Keen to do what the government wants now
they may say it's in the longer term
interest of the BBC it's about the
funding of the BBC it's about the
license fee it's about the future of the
World Service the trouble is there are
moments when the BBC has to turn to the
government and say we're not doing it
your way
Gary lineker's made it clear he won't be
apologizing he insists he hasn't broken
any guidelines what's beyond dispute is
that the BBC could have handled this
differently and it's now struggling to
contain the crisis Nadine barber Al
Jazeera London
well eight and white is the founder and
president of the ethical journalism
Network and he joins us live now from
London good to have you on the program
sir I mean there are blunders bloopers
and sort of General jaw dropping gaffs
that media organizations experience all
the time but how much of a mess has the
BBC got itself into as it seems to be
mentioned across the media Network in
the UK
yeah I mean I think the BBC has got
itself into a real mess of course the
BBC has a strong and admirable ethical
base it's at the heart of its
International reputation as a fair and
independent broadcaster however due to
the events around the Gary lineker tweet
it is today accused of double standards
the fact of the matter is
um in recent years many presenters and
journalists at the BBC have robustly
expressed themselves on social media
while maintaining due impartiality when
they're on the air and that's exactly
what Gary lineker has done but he has
found himself singled out for treatment
uh and and and discipline so it's
brought into a focus and sharp Focus the
capacity of the BBC to maintain its
standards not just on impartiality but
elsewhere but a big question now
question mark exists over the question
of enforceability and the need for
consistency in the way that it enforces
its ethical rules but uh and and I think
that the BBC was going to have to find a
way of doing two things one is allowing
its uh Sports uh presentations to get
back on track and saving its reputation
it's it's a big task is there not a
third angle to what you've just said
about sports rep you know Sports
programs on board uh get them running
again BBC's reputation but the other
thing is about the role of presenters if
you create and I don't want to say Gary
Linda's a monster but if you create the
monster then of course it's very hard to
to keep that that whole ego or
conversation
corralled in uh presenters generally
have a responsibility do they not to
know the role that they fulfill within a
broadcasting organization if Gary
lineker is a sports presenter even if he
does tweet what he is tweeting does he
not himself have a responsibility to
realize what he's tweeting in the
position that he has and in the voice
that he has in the United Kingdom
oh you know I mean I think Gary linger
Gary is very well aware of the potential
influence he has that's why and he's
been very clear over the years this
isn't the first time he's he's found
himself in in the crosshairs of of
controversy over this issue he he has
made it very clear he checks very well
his Communications are not abusive he is
always impartial on the air he checks
very carefully before he decides to
publicize a tweet and and and and really
that's all that can be expected of
people who are in the public eye the
fact of the matter is that BBC has been
trying to control and manage big beasts
in broadcasting for for decades
um in recent times we've seen people
like Alan sugar uh uh people who have
really been able to influence and have a
big audience who've been able to express
themselves freely
um but it's the question is why is it
that linica has suddenly been singled
out and that's why the BBC's got itself
into an additional mess which is the
suggestion that has been some political
pressure applied in the end the BBC is
going to have to re-examine as Tim Davey
has said it's a policy regarding due
impartiality and it's going to have to
look at the question of enforceability
and also consistency if it begins to do
that and it opens up a debate evolving
asking its own presenters its own
journalists what they think about this
how it can be developed even asking
outside contributors like linnica and
others to take part in that review I
think they'll find a way to solve the
problem and just very briefly Mr works
of running out of time I'm just
wondering is it a case as you say that
the BBC has to take a step back and have
sort of like an independent commission
to work out how to move forward in a
scenario like this when social media and
the internet is so prevalent and that
one word can be you know broadcast all
over the world and interpreted in so
many different ways who would be on
those sorts of independent panels or
review bodies
I mean I think there are a fantastic
amount of sort of good uh experts who
can be brought in to sort of assist and
advise there's no doubt at all about it
but remember what we're talking about
here is a tweet for goodness sake and
you know whether I was ill-judged or not
the fact of the matter is it is getting
in the way of a proper debate about an
important shift in government policy I
think the BBC has to take itself out of
the headlines have a proper review and I
think it can find the right people to
help it carry out that review and to get
things back on track uh as soon as
possible it can do this and I think Tim
Daly has already indicated that that's
the path he's going to take I think if
he does that it'll be the right thing
we'll see what happens for the moment
Aiden White's so good to speak to you
thanks for joining us from London thank
you very much